lunch is Chris and slide this up um okay
great so our next speaker is Chris Hugh
and you'll be speaking about semantic
foundations for probabilistic program
thank you my name is Chris thank you for
having me I come from the University of
Edinburgh but this I'll be reporting on
joint work with a lots of people from
the University of Oxford and actually
Sam Staten was supposed to give this
talk but you fell ill he could make it
unfortunately so with two days notice
I'm here I'll tell you all about it and
Hong shook is already giving the next
talk so he also can we talk about this
the other thing I should say is I'll be
here for the rest of the month and I'm
very happy to work on anything you can
think of related to this or anything
else I'm interested in and i'll be
talking about semantic found ages for a
probabilistic programming i'm going to
start out to set the scene by insulting
all of the audience so there's sort of
two half to this semantic foundations
and probabilistic programming i'll have
two slides on each insulted as a bit
basic just to make sure we're all on the
same page okay so first semantic
foundations that's about if you want to
if you write a program you don't just
want to write the program you want to
prove that it does what you claim that
it does right and to be able to do that
you need some sort of mathematical model
to do your proof in so the idea of
semantics is you have your big bag of
programs here's two of them we're going
to assign to each program a semantics so
some sort of mathematical objects in
some Universal mathematical objects and
we're not just going to do it
willy-nilly of course we're going to do
it in such a way that if two programs
are related to each other in some way
for example they're concatenations of
two statements then the thing I assigned
to this combined object over here has to
have a similar kind of relationship to
the two opted to constituents objects I
assigned to those two statements
so the idea is that these mathematical
structures here are going to reflect the
structure of the programs there's
various ways of doing this we can do
this operationally you could think as
these kinds of mathematical objects I
might take literally some sort of state
machine that sort of execute the trace
of this program keep all the
implementation details along and that's
very handy if you want to think about
efficiency of a program the other thing
you can do and that's what I'll focus on
today mostly it's denotational semantics
so there you don't really care about the
actual implementation details of a
program but but conceptually sort of
what it does the point and oh sorry and
that's most useful if you want to talk
about correctness of a program so what
does it what does it say to be that a
program is correct you first sort of
need to know whether what it means what
it's correct against and the motivations
for doing this are typically and
especially in this probabilistic
programming community to ground the
programmers intuition in a sense so most
people that work with probabilistic
system have some sort of semantics in
mind and there might be some sort of
situation at all of all the people in
the community agree on but sometimes
it's not clear sometimes it's not
outspoken especially if some fancier
features come in like higher-order
function for example it's not clear what
the corner cases are so it helps to make
this explicit the other thing you can do
is so we might not know a lot about
these programs but we might understand
these mathematical structures very well
so for example if if these two programs
get set to the same semantics I have the
same meaning you could say sort of
they're both implementations are the
same algorithm and conversely you might
think the two programs compute the same
thing but if they have different
semantics that's ostensibly false all
right so you can check whether your
carefully design program transformation
is actually careful
typically these mathematical objects
traditionally they're taken to be
certain kinds of partial orders domains
where the partial order says sort of
this part partial evaluation of the
program is larger than that one but in
principle it can be any structure
whatsoever there can be objects in any
category and we're going to use this
later on okay then about probabilistic
programming dance talk set this up very
nicely I'm going to continue in that
kind of spirit as far as I'm concerned
it all starts with Bayes law there's
baseball the probability of a given B is
the same as probability of B given a
times probability of a all divided by
probability of B just a fact of life in
other words if I take out this
normalizing constant P of B that says
that probability of a given B is
proportional to the guilty of B given a
times that probability of a or award in
words the posterior is proportional to
the likelihood of an event happening
times the prior this is going to be a
slogan I'm going to use for a while
the kind of programming language that
I'm going to talk about it's called
Anglican it's a fork of church hence the
name so basically what they've done is
they take functional programming sort of
the something like Haskell the purest
functional programming language you can
think about and they add specific
constructs to talk about probabilistic
models and systems and inference
algorithms that correspond to these
these elements of Bayes law so for
example if I give you a prior in the
programming language you can sample from
the prior you can ask please give me a
sample now from this distribution you
gave me the likelihood corresponds to a
chromatic is called observe so suppose
you're writing some program you've
sampled your prior for a while and then
you get told look in the real world this
data happened he observed that event and
that influences you can draw inferences
from that and then there's something
called normalize so i divided by this
constant here that's sort of hidden in
this proportional to symbol it's going
to be explicit in the language so we
want to end up with a probability
distribution at the end of the day sort
of the weight of the whole space has to
be one I'll explain it later in more
detail
okay so here's the overview of i'm going
to do so i'm going to develop semantics
denotational semantics for this kind of
idealized anglican probabilistic
programming language i'm going to
interpret types as measurable spaces
it's a tight language so the meaning of
type is a measurable space and I'm going
to interpret programs statements I'm
going to take a very academic point of
view and call them terms and interpret
terms as kernels so terms with an input
type in an output type if you like
specifically that means that that the
close terms the ones without an input
type the ones that just compute
something I can be interpreted as
measures on on the type on the
measurable space that corresponds to its
type and then inference normalizes these
measures this is more or less standard
since texture cozen or maybe even
earlier we're going to add some features
to this basic first Euler set up
specifically i'm going to talk about
higher-order functions so that's a
program that can take a function as
input and pass it on as an output and
sort of change the argument in the
meantime and that is going to open up a
can of worms and we'll see how many
details I can tell you about that
specifically I said we're going to
interpret types as measurable spaces for
example the type of reals so this is
something in the programming language
i'm going to terp it as the actual real
number space with the Burrell Sigma
algebra if I also want higher order
functions I need to have some measurable
space to interpret the type of functions
from reel 2 reals it so happens that
there's rigid results saying there
cannot be any Sigma algebra whatsoever
no structure of a measurable space
whatsoever on the set of functions from
R to R so something needs to give there
I'm going to find a solution for that
and it's going to have some other issues
that we'll talk about i should mention
this is based on Alex paper this year
especially so this is mostly Sam's work
and these two things are new as well
it's not yet published anywhere
great which is by there is no measurable
structure that's spacer function you can
always put this yes so I left out some
crucial assumptions there so it's in
this paper if you want to look it up the
crucial assumption is that you want
evaluation to be measurable function all
you look at the function space of
functions are two are I have the space
are you can take the product of them and
then a function that evaluates a
function on a point to our let me write
it down
this function it stands to reason that
we want these funds that function to be
measurable Delta's you can there is no
measurable structure immeasurable space
on this set that makes this function
measurable so again this sorry to be a
pain in the night but you can always
take this magic regenerated by this map
right so there's another thing when
they're telling us you won't go really
in subsets of our to be measurable yes
the thing I'm hiding is we want this
product to be the actual product of
measurable spaces it's not so it's a
measurable structure of measurable space
and putting on here and then this this
thing is fixed it's not a structure
immeasurable space i can put on the
totality of this that you can do so
there's there's obstructions here is the
point i don't know a good application
for them but in principle that could be
if you move to equivalence classes with
respect to a fixed measure then you're
okay again okay I was about to ask you
in with I yields of negligible you can
also do that or do you have to commit to
a full-blown measure all right I mean it
can be the class of all measures
absolutely continuous or equivalent
that's of course with that said I don't
know what I deals are thank you thank
you this is a running example to try and
get you to understand the kind of
programs in this language that I'll talk
about well we toss a fair coin we get an
outcome X then depending on that outcome
x i'm going to set up a distribution
with one of exponential decay with one
or two rates either the yellow one or
the blue one if it comes up as saving to
the blue one if its tail's we do the
yellow one then someone tells us that
decay is so and so much what does this
tell us about our original coin flip
this is one of an informal description
of that of the experiment
here's how you would write it down an
Anglican the four lines of the
experiment pretty much correlate one to
one with the four lines of this program
I just said throw a fair coin call the
outcome X sample from it depending on
this rate sorry if it comes up heads
then the rates gonna be too if it comes
up tails and rates going to be one so
you get the yellow and the blue one and
then we set up the distribution we're
interested in and we observe that
something happened and we return X so
that sort of calculates for us this
compiles to a program that gives you the
probability of the posterior really on X
what does this program mean what does it
do naively you could try just run
through all the possibilities like an
execution tree is the first line we
sample from the Bernoulli distribution
so either comes up head or it comes up
tails with so probability a half it
comes up heads let me call it true will
be in half it comes up false if we're in
this branch of the tree if X was true
then here I'm going to assign to to our
let me get back to score in a minute I'm
going to return true in the end it comes
up false I'm going to assign rate 1 i'm
going to return false but in a sense so
this trace is as twice as much weight as
this one is what the score is supposed
to say we're going to sort of keep that
score we can accumulate the score when
we do the execution if there's my slogan
posterior is proportional to likelihood
times prior here we have our likelihood
and our priors so this is the posterior
to measure at the end except that is not
really probability measure if I wish to
take this at face value the probability
that X was true was going to be 1
probability is false give me a half that
doesn't add up to 1 so it's not
probability measure I need to normalize
it total weight of these scores is 3 i'm
so i need to divide by sort of three
times a half
the end of the day the posterior is
going to be two thirds chances are true
one-third chance of the false and the
model evidence that I've / I'm going to
remember was one and a half Apple clear
I think I wish the score where is the
score coming from this one that was a
sort of it comes from that observe if
you like
observe is the key word in the language
some sorcery sorry i think i'm using
them interchangeably sometimes its core
sometimes it was observe i tried to
color code them so red means red
so one would understand this is it just
imagine each execution had someone
global variable that keep track of the
current score of the particular
execution so whenever you get execution
encounters observe it evaluates some
expression there essentially look at
probability density functions evaluated
with respect to the given data and then
that data will become a new score that
gets multiplied by your current squad so
this global variable tractor score they
keep getting multiplied by various
objects statement they can compute the
likelihood school light will be
probability not necessarily after you
normalize of course it will be
the density over here to this
so here there were only two possible
execution trations because it only
depends on whether the coin comes up
heads or tails in other words because
this was the Bernoulli distribution we
sampled but it could be many other
possibly continuous distributions if it
were a normal distribution for example
there would be not only in fluent in any
execution paths we could take there
would be uncountably penny a problem we
couldn't sort of add uncountably many
nonzero numbers that's what I'm going to
use measurable spaces are you sure how
up to speed everyone is with this but
the basic point of it is that the
probability of sampling sampling one
specific point is always going to be
zero and yet if I if I ask that my
sample lies within an interval is going
to be a nonzero probability so all of
these slices these uncountably many
slices add up to are all zero but they
add up to something non zero your theory
of solves for you it's literally a
measurable space is a set with some
family of subsets that will call
measurable so these are the events you
can observe sort of and a measure on
that space is a function that assigns to
a measurable set a number such a way
that it takes disjoint unions twosomes
comfortable ones countable as the key
word here
just to make sure on the same page so
here is the official language i'll be
talking about it's typed language so it
has types the types i'm going to allow
our first of all the real numbers i have
any type a I'm going to allow a
distribution type that takes probability
distributions on a and I'm going to
allow finite products and countable sums
specifically once I have this I can
build for example bullion's by doing one
plus one or i can take naturals by doing
accountable sum of one oops and terms
come in to type come come come in two
variations there's going to be program
statements that are deterministic that
don't depend on any probability
distribution or sampling later on
there's going to be one that are
probabilistic so the terminus tecton's
are sort of the boring ones you can have
variables you can have things to make
these sums and products work nicely the
interesting one is any measurable
function whatsoever I'm going to allow
as a statement in my language
specifically something like the
Bernoulli distribution that we've just
used you could see that as a measurable
function from the singleton set to the
set of probability distributions on our
so those are allowed terms in my
language so there's a bunch of examples
so this is supposed to say given no
context the following is a deterministic
term 42 of type real right because 42 if
you like is a measurable function from
the singleton set to the real numbers
all these kind of things
and there's the probabilistic terms
these are more interesting will allow
sequencing just so we can do function of
things return and let and here's the two
primitives that we're going to add the
score and sample observant sample score
just says the thing I've observed if T
is some real number deterministically
not depending on probabilistically on
the contest on the input and score of T
is going to be going to be a singleton
sorry a term of type 1 there's going to
be a probabilistic term and similarly if
T is some distribution on a then sample
of T is going to be going to give me
sort of an element of a tank T type 8 ok
so these are two of my colors here's the
third I'll i'll call it a norm
normalization i'll have a whole slide on
that in a minute that's the language now
i'm going to give the semantics going to
build this up hand by hand you can I
sort of add features to both as we go
along so as I said we're going to
interpret types as measurable spaces
deterministic terms are going to be
measurable functions so a term
deterministic term tea with Khan in
context gamma of type a can be a
measurable function from sort of a
meeting of gamma to the meaning of a
probabilistic terms are going to be
Colonels so these are functions of this
type from a probabilistic term in
context Gamma Phi a is a function from
the meaning of gamma times the Sigma
algebra of the meaning of a so these are
the measurables s in a two numbers in
such a way that if I fix the first
argument if I take an element here and
fix it the function i have left is going
to be a measure if i take a measurable
set and fix that the function i have
left is going to be a measurable
function
hey so
heroes my language is sort of obvious
how to interpret all of these things and
how to interpret that let me talk about
these two because they are the
interesting ones so if I have a term
score of tea it has this type it's a
probabilistic term so it's going to be a
colonel from gamma times Sigma algebra
of one just a discrete set discrete
measurable space on the singleton
elements do a number so here's my ice
cream basically i need to give it a
gamma and i need to produce a number and
i'm just going to evaluate t sort of on
that on that input
sample sort of does it and the other
argument if you like through the types
now you need to evaluate e not just on
gamma but also on some sub measurable
subset
and that basically comes down to
integration if you want to change
statements together it comes down to
integrating out the middle variable the
middle type
so just I've lost track to small gamma
is an instance of a environment capital
gamma or yes Morgan was an element of
this measurable space solo bracket
bracket
I was hesitating whether i should put
these explicit formulas because they put
people to sleep typically provide your
week okay so here's the running example
we saw that this is a well type program
make sense now what does it mean we can
sort of interpret it and find its
semantics also the meaning of a program
it's a closed program has no input so
it's going to be a measure on on the
space on its type in this case the type
it returns X so it's type is either true
or false it's a billions with the
discrete Sigma algebra on it and the
meaning of this is a measure on the two
elements set so i need to get tell you
what size is what measures we assign to
all possible measurable subsets here's
all four of them and we calculated
before what it does I am always measure
zero these were the two probabilities
more probabilities but measures we
calculated they added up to the whole
space saving measure one and a half the
meaning of this program
okay now let me talk about this
normalization procedure this this is the
I'm going to allow statements of type of
the form norm of t where t is some type
of drum hey it's going to have this type
either it's going to be a real number
and the probability distribution on a or
is going to be one of those two either
going to represent some errors so I
think of a normalization of t as I
remember the model evidence and I
remember the normalized posterior or
some errors
so how do and how do I interpret this
well it's a probabilistic term so it's
going to be a colonel in general so it's
going to have this type i need to find
sorry a kernel of this type and remember
Colonel the definition of it is if I fix
the first argument the thing if I leave
out this the thing I have left here is
going to be a measure so this thing is a
measure of course if i divide by the
weight of the whole space i'm going to
get a probability measure so this is the
posterior then I'm going to put in there
and this normalizing constant is the I'm
going to remember that the model
evidence is going to go in there it
could of course be the case that this
mobile evidence is normalizing constant
here 0 or infinity and n I'm in trouble
I can't divide so I'm just gonna that's
what normalized us so here's our example
program this is the meaning we just
assigned to it that's normalized this
thing so that means I normalize this
distribution it's going to look like a
fair Cornwall not fair a coin with
probability two-thirds model evidence
was one and a half and this in one just
means it's in this term of the sum it's
not one of the errors
so now we can prove all kinds of program
transformations correct so here for
example is sequential Monte Carlo
basically one of the key steps and it
comes down to this statement that you
can sort of unroll once and discard
powerful if it's no good so this is sort
of a more efficient version of that and
you can compute the interpretation for
both sides and they come out to be the
same so this step is actually justified
and of course that's what programmers
have in mind when they do this
and there's lots of more examples you
can calculate you can do an important
sampling where for example suppose we
know that exponential distribution is
hard to compute the sample from but a
normal distribution is easy we can try
and use the normal 12 to simulate
sampling the exponential one in such a
way you can prove these two examples
sorry these two statements equal the
meaning of them is equal other one can
do is I could unroll this one further
this sort of first I score by that and
then ups my score by one over this this
is also equal to that if you normalize
all of them so these two programs were
the same as if I'm normalize both of
them they're still going to be the same
let's suppose I don't just normalize the
whole thing but I normalize the first
two and then use that to go on and then
normalize the end result that's not
going to be the same thing if you
normalize these to effectively you'll be
sampling the lebesgue distributions
that's going to give sort of the
infinity error so you normalize at the
end of the whole run not halfway and
keep going of course people know this
but it's good to see how it actually
works
let me skip this
examples you can have a look at maybe
this one is a fun one to look at because
i think i saw was asking about it
yesterday look at this program first you
observe you sample the beta distribution
and then you observe that samba newly
based on it is true another thing you
could do is first observe and then
sample another beta of a beta with
different parameters so this is called
conjugate priors this is the conjugate
prior for that so you can't quite switch
these lines but almost up to changing
the distribution you can prove that
these two semantics are equal so that
means using computer algebra if you like
or just pen and paper you can prove that
they are the same but in the programming
language in the probabilistic
programming language you know there are
different programs so that's sort of the
two sides of this question yesterday let
me push on to talk about higher-order
functions so these are functions if you
allow your programming language to take
to write functions that take functions
is input and pass functions through as
output these things actually get used
here's a paper of dance actually in some
horrible Lisp notation but the point is
this defines some function and indian
buffered process it takes a measure and
I've actually uses a measure later on of
course measures are function types so
take something a function type and uses
it these things games this point and
anglican actually allows the user
higher-order functions if they don't
really know what it means and if it goes
well all the time
okay so here are the types we had before
we're going to allow function gibes now
if a is type and visa type I'm going to
allow the type of functions to space a
function from A to B well as we saw
before in this specific sense are as a
type so I should be able to make the
type r arrow are and I want to interpret
types as measurable spaces but you know
we can't do this so our arrow are if I
literally take all the measurable
functions from R to R that's no good we
need to take something else to interpret
this time operationally that's easy to
do but I'm focusing on the denotation
now so what how do we handle this this
is where category theory comes to the
rescue I know Kat could get a bad name
occasionally but they're actually useful
as i'm going to show you now so we were
interpreting our types as measurable
spaces and we know that there are not
enough function spaces in there to make
to allow us interpret function types so
we're going to do is embed this universe
into a larger one that does have enough
function spaces specifically we're going
to use sheaves or measurable spaces
these are certain types of functors that
assigned to each measurable space is set
and I want them to preserve countable
products for technical reasons i walking
into the point is this is a fine
universe of mathematical structures that
we can interpret our programs in and it
does have all function spaces so
basically we've sort of completed this
universe by throwing in all function
space inform throwing in all function
spaces formally and this embedding here
the Uneeda embedding preserves all
structure you could dream of so
everything that held here still holds
here now we do have function types
actually I'm slightly lying there's a
bit more work you have to do and so
where did we go we had this type right
if a is a type then I allow terms have
it as type probability distributions on
a and I didn't really talk about how we
interpret that but that's basically buy
this thing ecology Ramon add something
if you take a measurable space eight and
the probability distribution so they are
again a measurable space so that's a map
that goes here if I want to extend my
semantics to over on the right side I
better have a similar thing over here
that by abstract nonsense called count
extensions and it works perfectly
there's one thing i'm brushing on the
drug here which is for this trick to
work for this thing to exist I can't
take all measurable spaces I need to
have assets worth of them another proper
class so you need to restrict to nice
enough measurable spaces Santa Braille
spaces will do for example
okay so now we have a larger universe
where we can interpret a lot of stuff so
you might ask what are these function
types look now look like now over here
so for example this this problematic
type of our arrow are what what is it
it's some sort of object here but what
does it look like it turns out if you
ask about to what its points are what is
elements are if you like so what what
chief does this thing denote there's out
to be exactly the random functions and
that's the name people have for
measurable functions from a probability
space times R to R
clear
now finally I'm going to do two things
to this higher order semantics first
thing I'm going to do is so we can do
this formally so nice and well but these
are fairly complicated mathematical
structures let's try and find the easier
description for them and you can do that
so here's my new semantics from now on
instead of these sheaves I'm going to
work with something will call Kwazii
measurable spaces so I define that to be
a set not now with the family of subsets
I'll call measurable but with a subset
of functions from the reels to my set
that i'm going to call measurable and
have to satisfy some axioms it's a
measurable space you have to give
distinguish measurable subset there to
satisfy some axioms now we're going to
distinguish some functions into my space
that satisfy some axioms and that the
axioms I wanted to satisfy is I want to
be closed under pre composing with
measurable functions are two are
measurable real functions I was it
contain all the constant functions and I
wanted to have sort of countable
branching if you like specifically some
function f from our 10 is measurable and
for each n I have an element for myself
abstractly measurable functions here
then this function I also want to be
abstractly measurable
might be funny notation to you I mean
this function you get some real number
if I have to wait to get a natural
number and apply the f teeth function G
to my number
these work Kwazii measurable spaces any
measurable space is going to be an
example so that's sort of the intuition
behind them if X were an actual almost a
goodness measurable space and I can just
take for this set em to be all
measurable functions are takes it will
satisfy those axioms but there will be
more quasi measurable spacious and
measurable ones won't measure you're
taking on their discrete one measurable
right no measure measurable so just two
discrete l 3 Sigma algebra
if you look at these things and sort of
the homomorphisms that preserve the
right amount of structure they will form
a Cartesian close category with
countable sums as a fancy name for the
kind of category I need to interpret my
language in Cartesian close means I can
have my function types Grantham's means
I can have my songs and a funny thing
about this is a term supposed to have a
term a first order type that doesn't
involve any sort of higher order
nonsense in its input or output type it
might involve some it might be built up
there might be a concatenation of
statements half way you use higher order
types but as long as the input and
output types are first order then its
interpretation is going to be an actual
measurable function is so it's not going
to live in this solo in the world if
it's time lived here then its
interpretation will live there
so conservative extension if you like
schedule soon
and the final point I want to talk about
is recursion briefly
go
I don't get the relationship between the
closet immeasurable space and regional
space with any measurable space is an
example of a quasi measurable space but
there exists Kwazii measurable spaces
that are not do not come are not of that
born I can draw a Venn diagram if you
like yes asus
whether inside or quasi measure those
faces so the second of our inclusion not
always the case right it's not always
true that is that saying that the
singleton is a is measurable in if X is
measurable sorry first of all I have a
more basic question with this mean I
mean of course it means what you wrote
right that MX satisfies all your axiom
but can you recover this Matthew brown
you started from on ax that's a good
question i don't immediately have an
answer to I suspect so what I don't know
is it's one thing to say that if I give
you X and it's Sigma then you can
construct your max and it satisfies all
your free axioms there's another one to
say that you can cover the initial
structure I mean a priority I don't know
if the top of that but I think so I so
do I read correctly in this case that
the second axiom says that single terms
are measurable the single text is
measurable and I take for MX there are
all the measurable functions I mean if X
is a singleton set I know you for this
every single time in X oh maybe I can be
socially with this definition doesn't
achieve that there is any measure of X
right it's just right yeah it's just a
set by no structure suppose it wasn't
vegetables have a pleasure algebra find
all that yeah exactly so you say example
you say pika something that already has
a measurable structure and I can make
that quite a measurable structure out of
it yes so and you're saying so the
recipe is to say that the matter of the
you take flomax all the measurable
functions like this and so now i apply
axiom to it and that tells me that in
particular constant functions will be
that MX is that correct yes so to show
that this example satisfies the axioms
you have to show that constant functions
are measurable that's which is true no
it's not true I mean it's it's truly if
you if you have measurable means the
inverse image of a measurable set hair
is measurable there there's only two
ones here so the only inverse images you
can gather empty and the full thing and
they're both measurable mother use for
inclusion is view the vmx a set of
random variables on X so this is direct
try to directly formalized random
variable instead of sigma article
let me try and explain it to you after
it because i want to set up dating their
eyes to talk about something for 10
minutes and you think it's not true that
single terms are measurable not not
always 10 Singleton's exactly mask from
the constant function from R to axe
looks a lot to me like a single phone or
is not is not a toll bridge because
whenever you take whenever you take any
measurable search in X you take the
inverse function either these measures
that includes the point which is image
as a function for it doesn't and
therefore a racemic will either be the
whole space are or will be the empty
side right now these are both
immeasurable and the right initiative
measure yeah but so you think I only
indicator function of one of a single
turn up small axis is not an indicator
function this is the constant function I
think we are not going relatable
functions from next okay okay sorry
Chris maybe he's gay for three more
minutes yes I'm nearly done this is last
light I'm so what was it going to say
all right I haven't talked about
recursion so far so these measures sorry
Kwazii measurable spaces so far we're a
set with some structure on it and talk
about recursion we need to have some
sort of fixed point operator on this set
so instead of just a set i'm going to
ask that they are ordered sets with a
fixed point operator and one way to do
that is to ask their so called Omega
complete pressure orders and some nice
type of domain there's a partial order
that if you have an increasing sequence
non-decreasing officially there is some
sort of ideal point at the top of its
I'm least upper bound
okay so a cross immeasurable space i'll
call ordered when x is not just a set
but actually one of these things you can
compute fixed points moreover this set
of random stickam random elements if you
like of exit functions from our techs
that i'll call measurable I wanted to be
closed under this this operation of
taking least upper bounds so remember em
is
so all functions are 2 X if X is
partially ordered then this set the
function is a partially ordered is point
wise and if I can take supreme I NEX
then I could take supreme on here point
wise but that's not necessarily a
measurable function again I want I want
them to be closed under that operation
and a funny thing is that any domain any
Omega DCP or whatsoever for example the
unit interval will be an example of this
apt on it and again this gives the right
type of category for me to interpret my
language in as a Cartesian close
category with countable sums just to sum
up get that I've told you about
foundational semantics for probabilistic
programming that is idealized Anglican
language and I've developed a species of
mathematical structures in which we can
interpret faithfully all pretty much all
the structure you want from these
probabilistic programs we can have
continuous distributions we can have
soft constraints I didn't talk about
commutativity we could have higher order
things and we can add recursion all at
the same time and you can use this to
first of all verify that program
transformations for example in the
Anglican compiler are actually correct
that there's no bugs that it's safe you
might also go the other way and sort of
suggests program transformations
optimizations
and what I'd like to think about in the
future is something that will talk about
yesterday as well i think if i have a
bunch of programs that get better and
better so to speak when does it when do
they approximate some sort of ideal
program so how can you simulate for
example sampling some normal
distribution and what does that mean ok
I'll stop there thank you very much time
progressions so what one thing is is
there anything is there a clear relation
between this semantics you just showed
also the preaching of semantics yes
so those preciation mantesh mean this
one yeah cause immeasurable species that
are told you about our precisely
disorder the largest extensional sub
category that the largest well pointed
some country that's how we got it I see
and the other question is well I mean
there's a long-standing they are issue
in the bang theory about finding
Cartesian close category closed under
the probabilistic powered away so it
seems you found something which you can
use for a similar purpose by a different
minions I mean do you yes I'm aware of
that and that's something I want to work
on so this is this fairly fresh and it's
definitely not fully developed that's an
interesting direction surely yes
so I a question so in my work with
Cameron innate on the people analysis
mostly the interpret politic programs is
not merely medical functions functions
continuous on a measurement set for any
probability measure on a beautiful
polish space there's going to exist one
of these functions from said it couldn't
be that we could first of all do you see
this just does test continuity I measure
one set show up anywhere here do you
think you could use that as a basis
rather than measurability of course you
wouldn't want to have constants in your
language which are merely measurable
functions but maybe all the constants
are ya I don't know it's an interesting
question i don't know there are some
issues if you want to talk about
continuous density functions we're not
really sure how to handle them how did
how these fit in but this i think you
need to me so i really can't answer i
have a question about the the random
functions what kind of notion of random
functions you have in your model so i
think you talk so correct me if i'm
wrong but i understand that people buy
random function from X to Y mean a
measurable function from some Omega
times X to Y where Omega is a
probability comes with a probability
measure in all suggesting that modulo
some some conditions all the
technologies
is that the same thing as a priority on
just the space of all functions from X
to Y sorry prelude on a probability
distribution on all all functions from
for all measurable such functions or
calorie here what's going on is if you
apply extended Giri more ads on art our
arrow are in this pre-shift category
then you will gather mean in t2 virtual
user together to probability space on
functions but that's all defined in
terms of this pre-shift absurd nonsense
so but the one of what we found is that
we worked it out what does it really say
but it says is it's it just said so this
is mean intentionally what probability
space or property measure one function
actually look like and then it turns out
probability measure is actually a
measurable function from some
probability space times the source
measure over space to the target metro
space so if you is x and y are real
numbers it becomes very much like
continuous continuous time stochastic
process joint measurable measurable
continuous time stochastic process and
then one additional thing that's going
on here is because the GMO not if you
extend it there it is some big quotient
in you two going on so there are some
point equivalence class and they make
bunch of it into equal and that
intuitively correspond to say the
particular choice of this underlying
probability space doesn't really matter
so if you change underlying probability
space from Omega to Omega Prime but
things the random function were like
measured is too suggestive
continuous-time circus process on omega
and continuous time stochastic process
of Omega prime are somehow related then
they are considered the equal in this to
me
ok
any more questions all right thank you
very much